i
[Música]
[Aplausos]
bien
[Música]
cuando digo que soy matemática recibo en
general una de estas dos reacciones para
qué sirve la matemática
yo soy malísimo para la matemática en
cambio los que me conocen tienen una
tercera reacción
hacer la cuenta y nos decir cuánto pone
cada uno
ni hablar si uno dice que investiga
matemática ahí la reacción en general es
que si avanzando la matemática hay algo
más después de logaritmos
la visión de la matemática que tenemos
está reducida a algo inútil que es sólo
para unos pocos
consiste únicamente en hacer cuentas y
que es estático y acabado
claro con esta visión de la matemática
pareciera que no es importante aprender
matemática hoy total las cuentas las
hace el celular o nuestro matemático
amigo
sin embargo día a día nos bombardean con
datos como estos
para lo cual es indispensable saber
matemática para decodificar los
analizarlos críticas y autónomamente
formar nuestra propia opinión y tomar
mejores decisiones
pero no solo necesitamos más
conocimientos de probabilidad y
estadística vivimos en un mundo super
complejo e incierto abstracto donde
muchas de las tecnologías son
desarrolladas con una fuerte base
matemática seguridad informática
algoritmos de búsqueda publicidades en
redes para lo cual para poder opinar
críticamente y ser menos manipulables
necesitamos de una formación matemática
que nos ayude a entender un poco mejor
cómo funcionan estas cosas más aún los
problemas a los cuales tenemos que
enfrentarnos en este siglo cambio
climático pobreza desigualdad por
nombrar algunos requieren de habilidades
como la creatividad la resolución de
problemas la elaboración de estrategias
la optimización la anticipación
capacidades que la ser matemática nos
permite formar
la matemática es hoy más importante que
nunca
sin embargo para la mayoría la
matemática es esto
creer que la matemática es solo esto es
como creer que el fútbol es solo patear
córners
estoy solo en la cancha ni arco ay me
paro a la esquina pateó pum
listo algo técnico algo que casi ninguna
material necesita algo aburrido algo
solitario
y esto se transmite de generación en
generación
estoy convencida que todos podemos hacer
matemáticas como todos podemos jugar al
fútbol no todos vamos a hacer messi pero
sí vamos a ser capaces de jugar un
partido con amigos día a día se nos
presentan situaciones en las que hacemos
intuitivamente matemática inclusive
muchas de esas veces nos divierte
hacerlo
imagínense si pudiéramos educar esa
intuición tomaríamos mejores decisiones
y tendríamos más herramientas para
resolver problemas o argumentar
la clase corner creo que no hay que dar
muchos detalles abundan las definiciones
y la repetición de ejercicios técnicos
seguramente todos la conocen
en cambio la clase football invita a la
acción a que cada uno aporte desde su
mejor posición en este caso comienza con
una pregunta abierta a qué caja me
conviene ir que llevará el debate de
ideas ya que surjan nuevas preguntas de
que depende de la cantidad de personas
que tengo adelante de cuántos productos
tiene cada una
en qué medida de cada cosa
inclusive podrán ir al supermercado a
tomar tiempos reales donde van a surgir
nuevas preguntas para analizarlos
poco a poco con la guía del docente
construirá en un modelo podrán ponerlo a
prueba
eventualmente mejorarlo y aparecerán
finalmente las funciones lineales
si buscamos preguntas iniciales que les
interesen a nuestros estudiantes o mejor
aún preguntas que ellos mismos tengan
más se van a involucrar en la acción
casi en cualquier tema podemos plantear
preguntas que inviten a hacer
matemáticas
otro ejemplo de que de como dando
pequeñas vueltas de tuerca podemos
transformar clases córners en clases de
fútbol es este
la pregunta corner sería cuánto es 57
en cambio la pregunta fútbol es cómo
podemos sumar 12 esta pregunta
invita a la exploración es probable que
todos puedan dar una manera
tiene muchas soluciones y además tiene
la ventaja de que se pueden generar
nuevas preguntas hay más maneras cuántas
maneras hay y si en vez de sumar dos
números sumo tres y si en vez de sumar
multiplico es muchos problemas en uno y
dependiendo de cada estudiante será el
problema que resuelva
en este ejemplo
la clase de fútbol nos presenta un lado
simulado y nos invita a estudiar los
peces de este lado
qué preguntas nos podemos hacer
para responder estas preguntas lo único
que puedo hacer es pescar registrar lo
que crea conveniente y devolver los
peces al lago
algunas de las preguntas que surgen son
qué tipo de peces viven en el lago
cuántos colores y cuántos tipos de peces
tiene el lago cuántos peces tienen el
lago
cuántas pescas tengo que hacer para que
los resultados que obtengo sean
confiables
lo primero que debemos resolver es qué
preguntas puedo responder con este
experimento y qué preguntas no luego de
un trabajo en equipo se podrán analizar
los diferentes tipos de registro que uso
cada uno para evaluar ventajas y
desventajas
lo más importante es que voy a poder
analizar qué cosas puedo afirmar y qué
cosas no puedo afirmar con los datos que
tengo
para motivarnos traje para compartir con
ustedes algunas de las reacciones más
comunes que tienen docentes y
estudiantes cuando trabajan con
propuesta fútbol
ariel nos dice el trabajo con el
proyecto cómo puedo hacer para hacer un
buen mago fue como un gol de media
cancha porque los chicos se super
engancharon y estuvieron trabajando todo
el tiempo han hecho un festival de magia
que fue fabuloso donde les contaron a
los chicos más grandes lo que ellos
habían aprendido
a estos estudiantes del sexto grado les
propusimos que escribieran que pensaban
antes y que piensan ahora de la
matemática como pueden ver en él antes
vemos las reacciones de las que
hablábamos al principio números y
cuentas difícil aburrido una simple
materia que no sirve para nada
algo que jamás iba a aprender
en cambio después de unas cuantas
partidas de fútbol matemático las
opiniones van cambiando una materia que
te ayuda a la vida a que no te engañen
en el diario y sobre todo a pensar
algo increíble que te ayuda a descubrir
cosas
algo hermoso y un poco solo un poco
difícil
una ciencia muy distinta a otras donde
los patrones son la fuente de todo
estos testimonios nos incentivan a
seguir pensando porque no hay recetas
mágicas es trabajar día a día
equivocarse
animarse a probar otras cosas escuchar
estudiantes y a docentes y seguir
investigando
en los últimos años fui compartiendo
estas ganas de contagiar la pasión por
cómo nos puede mejorar la vida
desarrollar nuestro pensamiento
matemático y disfrutar de eso o al menos
desterrar el mito que muchas personas
tienen de yo no sirvo para la matemática
así nació mate de lado somos matemáticos
educadores estudiantes músicos y en
general personas que creemos que es
fundamental para el mundo actual
fortalecer la enseñanza y el aprendizaje
de la matemática generamos propuestas
para el aula junto a los docentes
trabajamos con estudiantes para entender
que los motiva y buscamos evidencias que
nos permita entender mejor cómo
aprendemos
para cambiar esta imagen de la
matemática todos podemos hacer algo por
ejemplo hoy los invito a todos aquellos
que crean que la matemática nos puede
ayudar a construir un mundo mejor a que
se sumen con nosotros a este proyecto
sostuve a claudia en quinto grado
mi maestra de matemáticas que junto a mi
profe teresa me incentivaron a descubrir
el fútbol en la matemática creo
que los que tuvimos la suerte de tener
en nuestras vidas
claudia soteres as tenemos que
involucrarnos para que cada vez más
gente sepa que la matemática es mucho
más distinta a lo que en general se
piensa y que todos podemos al menos de
forma amateur pero auténtica y relevante
hacer matemática gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]